[Applause]
all right y'all it's the holidays and we
picked out something perfect for the
season trending on social media this is
what I'm
[Music]
liking yall know I'm a sucker for a well
decorated Christmas tree really any
Christmas tree I love Christmas uh but
getting the lights and ornaments just
right can take some serious work
especially if you're not smart and buy
pre-lit whatever uh that's why I love
this hack in Alabama man came up with
after and while enjoying a little
wine
[Music]
I'm just saying we have this master
inventor on the line right now watching
on wvtm 13 in Birmingham what's up
Mike hello
Kelly all right so Mike you got to set
up this scene for us so you didn't have
a ladder that was a very clever thing
you did no actually the way it started
out was U of course it it's a wonderful
time to have Christmas and put the tree
up but uh this time the wife bought a
different tree and U uh she brought in
two boxes and I thought what the hell
you know this is this is a construction
site now it's not just taking a box out
of the box and setting it on the coffee
table putting a ball on it so yeah I got
the step ladder and I got ready to uh
put the lights on it turn around She's
Walking Away with the step ladder said
had way too much wine already so had to
think fast BR so clever and you are so
welcome on this show anytime man your
accent is I'm loving it and you are so
funny so this kind of this this blew up
this made you famous in town right oh
yeah yeah of course I live in a little
town um I shared it with the with the
people at work my friends the people I
hang out with and uh well was no time
they're spreading that around everywhere
so I'm where I'm at right
[Applause]
I would love to hang out with
you you are like a member of my family
it is insane how we are similar um thank
you so much Mike for the Innovative
creative idea that was very smart thing
to do with that broom because it's the
perfect bristles you know to go through
that was very smart thank you for
sharing I'm liking your post right now
Mike I'm loving you uh that's not all
the our season long part pilot pin
makers of precise the go-to pin of the
Kelly Clarkson show want to honor truly
truly incredible people just like you so
they're going to be writing you a check
for
$1,000 oh that's great thank you thanks
Mike thank you to all our guests this
hour share Lyla lockart crer Big Time
Rush Lauren Daran and O the elf yall
have a great day and if it's not try and
change
[Music]
it
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home